[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen es ist das erste mal
dass eine qualifikantin die us open
gewonnen hat mehr dazu von norbert
lehmann
die großen themen in dieser sendung
letzte vorbereitungen vor dem kandidaten
trail in gut einer stunde treten scholz
laschet und berbalk gegeneinander an
die angst vor den taliban wächst vor
frauen wird die situation in afghanistan
immer gefährlicher und
riesen überraschung bei den us open die
erst 18 jährige britin emma ducato
gewinnt das turnier ohne einen einzigen
satzverlust
für die kanzlerkandidatin und kandidatin
ist es eine der letzten möglichkeiten
vor einem millionen publikum zu punkten
heute abend treffen sie beim tv-duell
vom zdf und ard aufeinander genau zwei
wochen vor der bundestagswahl nach dem
neuen zdf politbarometer liegt olaf
scholz derzeit vorn seine spd kommt in
der sonntagsfrage auf 25 prozent
armin laschet liegt momentan dahinter
die union bei 22 prozent gefolgt von
annalena baerbock und den grünen auf 17
prozent würden sie dem nachkommen vor
wenigen minuten ist annalena baerbock
als erster im studio berlin angekommen
anhänger und anhängerinnen von allen
drei parteien stehen davor zur
unterstützung
und dort steht für uns auch stark und
hat manager controller was bedeutet
diese ausgangslage für scholz laschet
und berbalk fürs training
also alle drei werden hier sicherlich
ein wenig angespannt ankommen auch wenn
die anhänger der jeweiligen kandidaten
und kandidatinnen hinter mir schon
mächtig stimmung machen man hört das
vielleicht auch so ist sogar mit musik
unterstützt aber die erwartungshaltung
ist natürlich groß vor allem an armin
laschet richtet sich aus der eigenen
partei die erwartung dass er hier heute
eine trendwende einleiten raus aus der
negativen stimmung wir haben es in den
letzten tagen auch gehört dass er jetzt
vermehrt sagt es muss nicht unbedingt
derjenige ins kanzleramt einziehen der
den ersten platz macht werden die cdu
liegt eben weiterhin abgeschlagen auf
dem zweiten platz annalena baerbock hat
sich in den letzten tagen darauf
konzentriert immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen dass sie die kandidatinnen
einzig möglichen wechsel seien auch das
sei auch das werden wir sicherlich heute
abend wieder hören ja und olaf scholz
geht mit dem größten umfrage polster in
dieses trial rhein wird aber sicherlich
auch nicht ganz einfach haben denn das
muss ja auch erst einmal hinüber retten
bis zur wahl und außerdem gibt es
vorwürfe gegen ihn und gerade
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen in
seine wohnung das finanzministerium auch
diesen fragen wird er sicherlich nicht
ausweichen können wird ein spannender
abend heute dankeschön aus berlin schock
unter lamberti um 20 auf 15 geht es also
los dass real live in zdf und ard
moderation maybrit illner und oliver
knörr und schon ab 1945 berichten wir
live in der zdf- heute
schauen wir jetzt auf die korona lage in
deutschland die zahlen gehen nach unten
das robert koch institut meldet
7345 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 3108 weniger als
vergangenen sonntag allerdings fehlen
zahlen aus baden württemberg acht
menschen starben im zusammenhang mit 19
auch die sieben tage incident sinkt auf
jetzt 80,2
eine gute nachricht für alle menschen
die rente kriegen im kommenden jahr
bekommen sie voraussichtlich ein zitat
ordentliches plus so die präsidenten der
deutschen rentenversicherung rosbach wie
hoch die rentenerhöhung ausfallen werde
steht rosbach zufolge aber erst im
nächsten frühjahr fest das hängt von der
lohnentwicklung im gesamten jahr 20 21
und wir blicken nach afghanistan rund
die hälfte der bevölkerung ist auf
humanitäre hilfe angewiesen so die un
sie hält daher morgen eine
geberkonferenz ab vor allem für frauen
wird die lage immer schwieriger da die
taliban ihre rechte einschränken
studentinnen müssen sich künftig
verschleiern und dürfen nur noch
getrennt von männern an den
universitäten unterrichtet werden katrin
eigendorf hat aktivistinnen in kabul
getroffen
die frauen die sich an diesem mittag in
einem restaurant in kabul versammeln
wollen widerstand leisten gegen die
taliban seitdem ihre proteste gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen wurden beraten wie es
weitergehen soll
wir müssen vorsichtig sein unser eigenes
leben schützen und auch dass unsere
freunde wir sollten uns nicht irgendwo
draußen treffen
weil es zu riskant ist in der
öffentlichkeit ein interview zu führen
fahren wir mit variabel nach hause
überall in den straßen sehen wir
bewaffnete taliban warum wagen es vor
allem frauen diesen männern die stirn zu
bieten
es sind vor allem die rechte der frauen
die jetzt mit füßen getreten werden
deswegen protestieren vor allem frauen
zu hause zeigt mariam die bilder der
letzten proteste mit tränengas und
schüssen in die luft wurden sie
vertrieben ihre freundin wurde dabei
verletzt in einem video klagt sie mutig
die taliban an droht damit zurück zu
kommen riskieren sie nicht ihr leben
möchte ich wissen
alle mädchen aber auch alle jungen
afghanistans hatten früher pläne
hoffnungen eine zukunft du kannst dir
das sicher vorstellen wenn ein mensch
all seine hoffnungen und pläne verliert
dann spielt die sorge um dein leben
keine rolle
beim abschied witten maria und ihrer
mutter wir müssten berichten was mit den
frauen afghanistans passiert die
internationale aufmerksamkeit sei jetzt
ihre einzige hoffnung
ins nachbarland iran der atomstreit ist
festgefahren in einem punkt aber gibt es
jetzt ein wenig bewegung so will die
iranische regierung der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde künftig wieder
erlauben ihre kameras zur überwachung
der iranischen nuklearanlagen zu warten
und speicherkarten auszutauschen die
video aufnahmen sollen aber weiter
versiegelt im iran bleiben
es waren politisch aufgeladene termine
papst franziskus hat heute ungarn
besucht bei einer messe vor
zehntausenden gläubigen in der
hauptstadt budapest rief zu offenheit
und respekt auf zuvor war franziskus
kurz mit ungarns ministerpräsident orban
zusammengekommen
der papst fordert immer wieder hilfe für
geflüchtete orban setzt dagegen auf eine
rigide anti flüchtlingspolitik
es ist eine hommage an den künstler der
monumente verhüllte und damit so vieles
zeigte
unvergessen christopher packte 1 dem
berliner reichstag gemeinsam mit seiner
frau jeanne-claude in der schweiz waren
es wenig später bäume die ein neues
kleid bekam das letzte werk konnte er
nicht mehr selbst vollenden jetzt
entsteht es mitten in paris eine art
andächtig rollen sie die bahnen aus mehr
als 100 höhen arbeiter verhüllen seit
dem frühen morgen den abbau triumph ein
lebenstraum des künstlerpaars christo
und jeanne-claude dessen erfüllung sie
jedoch nicht mehr miterleben können
ich probe abo coaching wir hier in paris
und in frankreich haben wirklich großes
glück dass christo und sein letztes
kunstwerk vermacht hat
im gegensatz zu dem was man denken würde
werte das den triumphbogen auf man packt
ihn ein um ihn aufzuwerten das ist
paradox ich finde es unglaublich
mit den vorbereitungen in paris wurde
bereits vor wochen begonnen auch
deutsche firmen sind beteiligt lieferten
25.000 quadratmeter wiederverwertbares
gewebe bauten die unterkonstruktion
größte herausforderung der denkmalschutz
und ein schonender umgang mit dem
gemäuer die idee hatte christo schon in
den 1960 er später skizzierte er die
details in einem seiner letzten
interviews erklärte er dem zdf wie ihn
das bauwerk beeindruckte als er kurz
nach dem studium nach paris kam
ich zum ersten mal in paris ankam hat
mir jemand einfach schon würde bonn
verschafft ein dienstmädchen zimmer in
der nähe der champs élysées ich hatte
den triumphbogen ständig vor augen er
war nur ein paar blocks entfernt von
meinem haus raus sein neffe leitet nun
das projekt vollendet christus
verhüllungskünstler bis anfang oktober
die stadt und ihre besucher in den bann
ziehen soll
beeindruckend auch der sieg von maradona
bei den us- open- ja das ganze
frauen-finale eine einzige sensation
zwei außenseiterinnen im endspiel zwei
teenager und die 18 jährige
qualifikantin aus großbritannien schlägt
die 19 jährige leila fernandez aus
kanada die erste britische tennis grand
slam siegerin seit 44 jahren als sich
die beiden teenager nach dem finale
umarmen sind respekt und anerkennung
groß beide haben bei den us open
außergewöhnliches geleistet
ich glaube das level in diesem finale
war sehr hoch und ich hoffe dass wir uns
noch bei vielen turnieren und vor allem
endspielen wiedersehen in diesem
hochklassigen finale erklärt die britin
raducanu etwas wuchtiger etwas
entschlossener
sie gewinnt den ersten satz nach einer
knappen stunde
emma hat so toll gespielt ich gratuliere
ihr und ihrem team aber ich bin auch
sehr stolz auf mich wie ich die letzten
beiden wochen gespielt habe ein ass von
raducanu beendet die partie 6 zu 4 und 6
3 vor drei monaten ist sie noch zur
schule gegangen jetzt kannte sich über
ein preisgeld von 25 millionen us dollar
im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga trennten sich
frankfurt und stuttgart unentschieden
eins zu eins die eintracht bleibt damit
in dieser saison weiter sieglos alle
begegnungen alle tore des vierten
spieltags übrigens ab mitternacht zu
sehen bei uns auf sportstudio de und in
der zdf- heute- app zur formel 1 da gab
es einen doppelerfolg für mclaren denn
ricardo siegte vorländer norris beim
großen preis von italien
dagegen schieden die beiden wm rivalen
max verstappen und lewis hamilton in der
26 runde durch eine kollision aus nach
dem kontakt landete verstappen shrek
wohl auf hamiltons mercedes beide fahrer
blieben unverletzt
sebastian vettel übrigens im ersten
martin wurde zwölfter das was vom sport
dankeschön harvard jetzt schauen wir
noch wie wird das wetter viele wolken im
norden aber es bleibt trocken im süden
scheint nach nebel die sonne in den
alpen gibt es einzelne schauer die
temperatur erreicht 18 grad an den
küsten und 27 grad am oberrhein ab
dienstag wird es unbeständiger und
danach immer kühler das heute-journal
können sie ab 21 50 seen mit christian
sievers